all right well now let's talk about the
drama over on the voice because
four-time winner Blake Shelton who loves
to dish it out well he got it back last
night he had a little bit of a rough
time with Miley and the game man this
has been tough not as far as getting
artists on my team and it's driving me
crazy right now the country crooner
spent most of night three of the Blind
Auditions hitting his button and
pleading his case but sadly no one sing
good want to join Team Blake duct tape
my mouth and I have a better chance of
you and Miley wasn't making the evening
and easier I think I could break you out
of that shyness not shot definitely not
that will teach you that you'll never
have to speak again finally Blake seemed
to be a shoo-in choice for the last
singer of the night a Texas cattle
rancher you guys were in the ranching
business y'all run yearlings getting
like more country than country I know
where the guy comes from and he'll know
I just felt like some sort of kinship to
this voice that I'm hearing behind man
to turn around and then see you and hear
your story I'd love to be a coach for
you big I had no idea what you were
talking about that's what I'm trying to
get away from though that cattle talk we
don't have to talk about cattle or
anything but even with the push from
Adam to join Blake's team Josh shocked
everyone and picked Alicia leaving Blake
empty-handed and full of regrets talking
about Kyle and he's like I'm trying not
to talk about that thing I've ever said